ok today we're going to be looking at a
single called pendulum swings we'll also
take a look at basic and transfers
[Music]
throughout these movements try and
imagine a connection between center of
your body and the cloth
I'm starting this movement by opening up
my right hip and letting the club to
swing from side to side
this starts to generate more momentum
with the club and it will start to lift
higher and higher if you know it's the
movement doesn't actually come from my
arm is driven by my car as I swing my
arms extend it they're not rigid the
club should peak level with my left and
right shoulder now just like the weight
of the club generating movement the
opposing sweet
as you can see I'm trying to keep it in
line with my sensei as I turn and as I
reduce my body movement the momentum of
the club should also reduce and
eventually stop
so as always what you practice on one
side Frances on the opposite
another thing to know I'm actually
tilting my hip on opposing sides to
enable the swing it's not just simply a
hip rotation
I'm holding with a saber group which is
gripping with the little finger and ring
finger
the index finger and middle finger loser
give control of the club
also if you move your arms in parallel
you might find this gives you a better
alignment
okay so there's a couple of common
mistakes the first two trying to lift
the club only using around if you're
going to do this type of isolated
training you might as well shoot
dumbbells
doing it this way is only going to
straighten your shoulder and wrist
second issue is leaning into this week
this will be because the club's too
heavy and it could pull you back at risk
of injury
so create alignment you want your spine
to be straight and your posture upright
and you want to maintain your stability
as it swings from side to side
[Music]
okay so let's have a look at
transferring answer hands as the club's
in motion
so I get a feel for the movement and
there should be a point in the swing
where they call breaches its height and
feels momentarily weightless
it's at this point the club can be
transferred to the hands by giving it a
slight push and passing it over
also just before a try making connection
with the other hand on the upswing this
is for control and safety reasons so the
clubs are caught flying off and hit
something or someone
so here's a clip in the slow-motion
close-up
okay I hope you found that helpful the
next Club video I'll be doing will
probably be on full circles feel free to
leave any comments or feedback below and
as always thanks again for watching